i think what it hangs on the
topic of whether we can convert
consciousness into an engineering
problem so like
is consciousness tied to our biology
because the moment we can
convert consciousness into a digital
form then we can
send it with that light sail to alpha
centauri until then
a robot is not carrying anything except
maybe some basic knowledge like
wikipedia it's not carrying
the flame of human consciousness i have
high hopes
for converting consciousness into
engineering problem
in fact i think it's not as difficult as
people think i'm i
agree with that i'm definitely in the
camp that consciousness is
a property of the algorithm and not a
property of brain structure
um the other fun like the kinds of
philosophical things we'd have to graph
with grapple with is like
once you upload yourself like you can
hit control c you know like
it would be wouldn't be lovely to have
like 10 copies of fellow experiment and
then
like we could just interview everyone so
this is i mean this is
i i have to ask this question it's a
difficult one which
i don't think it'd be wonderful first of
all um
sure so in the following way and this
has to do with immortality as well
there's something about scarcity that
creates
value or um there's a bunch of
philosophers victor franco
bernard williams ernest becker they
argue that
death or the scarcity of life creates
meaning
and the reason we life is beautiful
the reason so many moments of experience
of
of love or delicious food all those
things are made
delicious because they're finite because
they end and because we don't have that
many of them
and there's a kind of worry that if we
extend the human lifespan
if we achieve immortality or if we god
forbid
clone uh me
multiple times then you lose the
richness of what it means
to have this life to have this
experience
is that worry you at all do you think
there's some aspect to which
death does in fact give meaning to life
i guess like
the one historical parallel and like
this might be a bit unfair is that you
know
there have been philosophers that said
that have said things like
you know war gives like meaning to human
collectives and
the struggle for supremacy between you
know nations and races as this
like big driver of progress that like
that ensures that
that everyone strives to be their best
and um you know of course
this viewpoint got into the head of a
crazy austrian guy and 20 years later
his soldiers were shooting at my
grandparents
um so you know these days we don't
really
have that but yet life still feels
meaningful there's we've still found
other ways to uh
for them like they're still uh us
driving for technological progress
there's still
um you know as us driving for
self-improvement in general
and it turns out that you know you don't
actually need to have existential
conflicts in order to
in order to have that now maybe you need
conflict but we have other kinds of
conflicts right like we have
you know competition between businesses
competition between political ideologies
competition
between projects and so you know these
are
like whatever what whatever the
psychological needs are like they're
just our substitutes for it
so i guess like yeah so if we yeah
i'm trying to say i i feel like once we
start
living to the age of uh 200 then
like i'm just intuitively expecting that
we'll see some like
the substitutes emerge in the same way
yeah that
will will create conflicts of other
sorts that lead to less human suffering
than wars do like we'll we'll just start
playing diablo 4 5
6 and because you die in video games so
maybe we'll get
some of the inkling of scarcity
through the activities we partake in as
opposed to our own body dying
i mean i feel shitty when i uh like you
can you i remember
in diablo 3 you can play in hardcore
mode
where if you die in the game your
character is dead maybe you will get
the the richness of like what that we
currently get from life
by having like little artificial
versions of ourselves that die
interestingly enough as i've just like
personally spent more time in this world
i've started realizing that you know
there is a concept of like
real fight finiteness that still like
exists and it might even still be a
thing that provides meaning that doesn't
require anyone to actually die
like for example like how many people
from
middle school or even high school or
yours like do you still talk to it
regularly
i'm happy to be close friends with like
four or five of them okay well like in
my case the answer is zero for middle
school and two for high school you're
right
right it dropped exactly it dropped
right and so like there's a lot of these
just like relationships that end up
being very finite um
a person changes their i feel like a
person changes enough of their worldview
after 25 years was that there even a
study about this something like
a person and themselves 25 years later
are about as different as like
two different people or something like
this um
so you know like i mean just like you
can have conflict without bloodshed i
think um you know you
you can have finiteness and even you
know the the necessary
sorrows of a finiteness that give
meaning without like
literally any anyone having to end their
life and hopefully if we do extend our
life
we'll figure out ways to extend the
period of time where there's newer
neuroplasticity yes to where we could
change our world views
continually throughout that time so you
can absolutely different phases of life
you